Nous allons ce matin, donc c'est un peu dans la continuité, je pense que j'aurais pu continuer dans Ézéchiel.
Je me suis dit aussi qu'on va être dans la continuité de Philippiens.
C'est vrai que le Seigneur peut toujours nous bénir aussi, même en écoutant Ézéchiel, tout ça.
Je parle pour ceux qui connaissent un peu le contexte où nous sommes actuellement dans Ézéchiel.
Mais le Seigneur a conduit les choses de façon à ce que nous soyons sur le psaume 1 ce matin.
Je pense que c'est un des psaumes les plus connus de la Bible.
On va même dire que c'est un des passages les plus connus de la Bible.
Je me souviens même quand j'étais plus jeune, souvent à la fin de l'année, il y avait des enfants qui venaient réciter les versets bibliques.
Ça, c'était le psaume 1. Beaucoup d'enfants mémorisaient le psaume 1 et parlaient du psaume 1.
Le psaume 1, c'est une introduction au livre des psaumes.
C'est le premier livre, on va dire un peu le premier livre des psaumes tout entier.
Et c'est lui qui donne un peu le temps de ce que sera la suite des livres.
C'est-à-dire quand vous allez lire la suite des psaumes, il y en a 150.
Vous allez voir que nous sommes toujours à peu près dans cette même continuité.
Les psaumes se divisent en plusieurs livres.
Il y a des psaumes de sagesse, il y a des psaumes d'imprécation, il y a des psaumes très divers pour la délivrance.
Donc, il y a beaucoup de choses.
Le psaume 1 fait partie de ce qu'on appelle les psaumes de sagesse.
Alors, bien entendu, c'est un passage qui est très riche parce que si on se met à rentrer dans le détail du psaume 1,
c'est plusieurs prédications qu'il nous faudrait.
Mais aujourd'hui, ce matin, on va juste parcourir ce bloc de versets.
On ne va pas rentrer dans toute la richesse.
Mais d'une certaine façon, nous allons essayer de voir aussi qu'est-ce que le Seigneur veut nous dire
au travers du temps que nous aurons ce matin là-dessus.
Et pour plus de sagesse.
Ça va dans le sens.
Donc, d'une certaine façon, le psaume 1 rejoint le thème central de la Bible.
Alors, le thème central de la Bible, c'est de nous interroger sur la question des hommes.
Le thème central de la Bible, c'est de nous interroger sur la façon de vivre ici-bas et notre destinée finale.
Mais ce qu'elle nous met en avant, c'est que Dieu est le maître de l'histoire.
C'est-à-dire que quand nous lisons la Bible, c'est le filigrane, c'est que Dieu est le maître de l'histoire.
Et ça nous montre l'interaction entre Dieu et les hommes.
Et le psaume 1 vient un peu vraiment dans ce sens aussi.
La vérité centrale, on va même dire, du psaume 1, c'est de nous dire que Dieu regarde la voix des hommes.
Que les hommes aient conscience ou pas que Dieu les regarde.
Que les hommes l'acceptent ou pas que Dieu les regarde.
Dieu regarde la voix des hommes.
Et c'est ce que le psaume 1 est en train de nous décrire.
Il nous décrit, sur ce que nous venons de lire, il va nous décrire à un moment la sainteté, le bonheur qui est attaché pour un homme que Dieu approuve.
Donc ça c'est sur les premiers versets.
Ça nous décrit aussi le péché, la misère spirituelle qui peut accompagner une personne qui rejette Dieu.
Ou que Dieu rejette.
Parce que c'est même aussi dans ce sens que je vais dire.
À un moment quand la voix que nous sommes en train de suivre n'est pas en train de plaire à Dieu.
Dieu nous rejette.
Et à la fin du psaume, on voit les destinées parallèles qui attendent chacune de ces personnes.
Et donc on peut dire dans un sens que ce psaume décrit l'histoire de l'humanité.
Depuis la chute d'Adam et Ève dans le jardin jusqu'à présent, le psaume 1 peut être une sorte de condensé de l'histoire de l'humanité.
Sur le premier point, quand il décrit la sainteté et le bonheur selon Dieu, c'est très important de préciser.
Parce que quand nous sommes en train de voir ça, il y a une emphase qui est dit à un moment, mais qui trouve son plaisir dans la loi de l'éternel.
Donc le psaume est en train de parler de trouver son bonheur selon Dieu.
Donc nous allons voir sur le premier point, la sainteté et le bonheur selon Dieu, pour un homme que Dieu approuve.
Et le premier point, je vais dire un peu le petit a de cette première partie, c'est le premier mot, heureux.
L'adjectif heureux, c'est un adjectif qui renvoie à une notion de joie profonde.
Vous êtes extrêmement content, vous avez une sorte de satisfaction qui est assez pleine.
Je vais dire que les supporters du PSG savent de quoi je parle depuis hier soir.
Bien que ça ne comble pas toute la joie d'un cœur, ça ne comble pas tout un cœur dans une joie.
Mais heureux, cette satisfaction, c'est le fait de ressentir un bonheur immense.
Et dans le sens de ce que la Bible nous enseigne, cela nous parle d'un contentement que nous ne pouvons trouver qu'en Dieu.
Cela nous parle d'une joie, d'une paix qu'on ne peut trouver qu'en Dieu.
Et ça, quelles que soient les circonstances de la vie.
Donc le dessin qui nous est fait, on va nous dire un moment que l'homme qui ne marche pas selon le conseil des méchants et toutes les choses,
c'est quelqu'un qui est comme un arbre planté près d'un courant d'eau.
Donc l'image est prise.
L'image est prise, elle est en train de nous montrer un moment qu'on contraste.
Alors là aussi, c'est encore intéressant.
Quand Dieu prend cet exemple avec le psaume 1, nous pouvons voir un moment que si vous allez en Israël,
pour ceux qui ont déjà eu l'occasion d'aller en Israël, Israël c'est un désert.
Une grande partie du territoire, c'est le désert.
Et c'est intéressant de voir le contraste que Dieu fait lorsqu'il prend ce psaume 1,
en disant au moment qu'avec le contraste des terres arides d'Israël,
on peut trouver des arbres qui n'avaient pas à subir l'aridité du désert.
On peut trouver des arbres qui étaient plantés près d'un cour d'eau.
Donc là, ce qui est aussi important, c'est que le mot littéral, c'est « planter auprès d'un cour d'eau ».
Ce n'est pas un arbre qui est auprès d'un cour d'eau.
C'est-à-dire, dans le mot littéral, hébreu et autre, c'est un arbre qui a été transplanté.
On l'a pris, on l'a placé.
Et ça a toute son importance aussi pour nous.
Et donc, lorsque la Bible nous parle d'heureux,
l'homme qui trouve son plaisir dans la loi de l'éternel,
je vais dire que cela fait écho avec ce que nous sommes en train de recevoir dans Philippiens.
C'est un parallèle avec Philippiens,
où Paul va nous dire un moment,
« Au reste, mes frères, réjouissez-vous dans le Seigneur ».
Le fait de trouver cette joie,
il est en train de dire,
« Celui qui trouve sa joie dans le Seigneur,
le Seigneur est pour lui comme un cour d'eau qui est planté près d'un arbre. »
Et donc, malgré les difficultés du désert,
malgré l'aridité qui est autour,
cet arbre arrive à prospérer, à porter du fruit,
parce qu'il est planté auprès d'un cour d'eau.
Donc, l'autre jour, c'est vrai que j'avais rappelé un peu
des principes d'agriculture quand on retourne la terre avant de planter les graines.
Là, j'espère aussi qu'on connaît un peu le principe des arbres,
parce que l'arbre, quand on parle de ça, c'est les racines.
C'est-à-dire, les racines de l'arbre vont jusqu'à là où il y a le courant d'eau
et appuisent ce dont l'arbre a besoin pour vivre.
C'est dans ce sens, les racines qui prennent en bas.
Et donc, le Seigneur nous dit un moment,
et je lis ce que Paul disait encore dans Philippiens.
Nous avons eu l'occasion de méditer là-dessus pendant la retraite.
Notre frère David est en train de nous exhorter aussi là-dessus.
Voilà ce que la parole de Dieu nous dit au sujet d'un homme heureux.
La parole de Dieu ne nous dit pas que c'est quelqu'un qui nage dans un océan de béatitude,
qui n'a pas de problème dans la vie,
où toutes les choses, tout ce qu'il fait lui réussit.
Même là encore, c'est une mauvaise interprétation que certains ont de comprendre cela.
Non.
La parole de Dieu nous dit à un moment que celui qui est heureux en Dieu,
malgré les difficultés de cette vie,
c'est quelqu'un qui apprend à se réjouir dans le Seigneur.
C'est quelqu'un, et David disait l'autre jour que un chrétien,
normalement un chrétien dépressif, ça n'existe pas.
Quand on va parler d'un chrétien dépressif,
c'est parce que le chrétien a choisi de fixer ses regards vers le bas,
on va dire même sur une autre vision là,
plutôt que d'élever les yeux vers le ciel.
Et lorsque nous regardons aux circonstances de vie,
et que nous laissons les circonstances de vie nous définir,
et même définir la façon de nous comporter,
on ne peut pas être heureux.
Personne ne peut être heureux.
C'est le principe même,
ce principe, c'est ce qu'il nous est dit quand ce même psaume nous parle du méchant.
C'est pourquoi les méchants ne résistent pas au jour du chemin.
Il dit, verset 4,
« Il n'en est pas ainsi des méchants,
ils sont comme la paille que le vent dissipe. »
Donc la paille, généralement, c'était les restes,
quand vous récoltez les détritus qui ne sont pas utilisés,
à un moment ça forme des tas,
et puis ça peut se balader, le vent les balade, toutes ces choses.
Voilà ce qu'est la paille.
La paille, il n'y a pas de consistance.
Et celui qui n'arrive pas à trouver son plaisir,
déjà dans le fait de se réjouir dans le Seigneur,
malgré les circonstances de vie,
oui, là on va parler d'un chrétien qui est dépressif,
mais ce n'est pas normal qu'un chrétien soit dépressif.
Parce que Paul dit à un moment que si
nous acceptons la paix de Dieu,
qui surpasse toute intelligence,
elle gardera nos cœurs et nos pensées en Jésus-Christ.
Donc, heureux l'homme qui choisit de placer ses affections en Dieu seul,
dans cet aspect, c'est ce que je viens encore de dire,
et je crois que la semaine dernière,
on avait commencé à aborder ce point.
Je fais beaucoup de parallèles aussi avec Philippien,
parce que je voulais aussi être un peu dans la continuité
de ce qui nous était déjà enseigné.
Paul dit, et c'est très difficile,
quand nous lisons ces passages, vous voyez,
dans beaucoup d'églises, c'est un passage qui est déformé.
Quand on lit Philippien 4, des versets 11 à 13,
la plupart, dans beaucoup d'églises,
on ne retient pas les versets 11 et 12,
on retient le verset 13.
« Je puis tout par celui qui me fortifie. »
Et donc, « je puis tout par celui qui me fortifie »,
ça veut dire qu'à un moment,
toutes les envies de notre cœur,
du moment où nous voulons aller dans le sens des envies de notre cœur,
Dieu doit pouvoir satisfaire cela.
Mais ce n'est pas l'explication de ce passage.
Et l'explication de ce passage,
ce n'est pas que je suis en train de dire
que ce soit quelque chose de facile,
mais c'est quelque chose qui nous permet de comprendre
pourquoi nous devons être comme un arbre
qui est planté près d'un courant d'eau.
Paul nous dit,
« Car j'ai appris à être content de l'état où je me trouve. »
Si nous ne sommes pas dans cet état,
à un moment, nous devons nous mettre à genoux,
nous devons prier pour que Dieu nous apprenne
à être content de l'état dans lequel nous nous trouvons.
Il dit, « Je sais vivre dans l'humiliation. »
Est-ce que nous sommes capables de dire,
« Maman, Seigneur, je sais vivre dans l'humiliation. »
« Je sais vivre dans l'abondance. »
« Je sais vivre dans l'humiliation et je sais vivre dans l'abondance. »
« En tout et partout, j'ai appris à être rassasié et à avoir faim. »
« À être dans l'abondance et à être dans la disette. »
« Et enfin, il finit, je puis tout par celui qui me fortifie. »
Pourquoi Paul est en train de dire ça ?
Pourquoi Jérémie se permet de le dire ?
Il y a même un passage de Jérémie, nous reviendrons là-dessus,
où il reprend intégralement le psaume 1,
sur une partie du psaume 1.
Si tu n'es pas planté auprès de ce courant d'eau,
en effet, tu ne sauras pas être content de l'état dans lequel tu te trouves.
Tu ne sauras pas rendre grâce à Dieu.
Toutes les choses seront, comme le dit la suite du psaume,
ne seront que misère, désert.
Vous voyez ce qu'il dit à un moment ?
Pour les méchants,
ils sont comme la paille que le vent dissipe,
mais c'était surtout la partie...
Ah oui, j'ai deux versions.
C'est pourquoi les méchants ne résistent pas au jour du jugement.
C'est pourquoi à un moment,
au niveau de la difficulté,
certains vont choisir
d'aller dans une voie
que Dieu n'approuve pas.
mais nous avons besoin
d'apprendre
et encore plus dans notre société
où nous avons eu l'habitude
d'avoir tout ce que nous voulons.
Si à un moment, nous n'avons pas l'argent
pour telle ou telle chose,
il suffit de prendre un crédit
et on aura...
On aimerait toujours avoir
tout ce qu'on aimerait avoir.
Tout ce qu'on aimerait avoir,
on va faire l'effort pour l'avoir.
On n'arrive plus à apprécier
ce que Dieu nous donne à un moment.
Et c'est bizarre,
c'est quand il y aura peut-être
une coupure de courant
que le réseau téléphonique ne marche pas,
qu'on va commencer à dire
mais je réalise que je peux être heureux.
Parce qu'à un moment,
on est dans un état
où on n'arrive plus à se contenter.
Mais heureux,
heureux l'homme qui ne marche pas
selon l'enquête des méchants.
Donc, sur cet aspect de heureux,
c'est de prendre conscience
à un moment
que nous devons travailler à notre cœur.
Et là encore,
je fais encore le parallèle
avec Philippien.
De considérer ces choses
qui peuvent être d'une telle importance
que si nous ne les avons pas,
nous ne nous sentons pas heureux.
Si à un moment,
ces choses ne sont pas manifestées
dans notre vie,
nous ne trouvons pas de paix.
Parce que cette chose manque
dans notre vie.
Et ce qui est bizarre,
c'est que nous ne réalisons pas
que souvent,
quand nous avons cette chose,
ça ne nous donne pas plus de joie que ça.
Voilà pourquoi là,
je parlais pour les supporters du PSG.
C'est une joie relative.
Le lendemain,
on se relève,
on se réveille,
mais les batailles de la vie sont là.
On va se réjouir un moment,
mais lundi,
il faudra repartir au travail,
il faudra repartir
avec toutes les batailles.
Mais ce dont nous avons besoin,
c'est de regarder à Christ.
Ce dont nous avons besoin,
c'est de réaliser un moment
que nous,
en tant que croyants,
la parole de Dieu nous dit
que nous sommes comme un arbre
qui a été transplanté près d'un courant d'eau.
Et cet arbre se nourrit
du courant d'eau
pour pouvoir fleurir,
pour pouvoir porter du fruit.
Et par là,
un moment,
à cause de l'excellence
de la connaissance de Christ,
cela nous amène
à regarder ces choses
comme étant des pertes.
Cela nous amène,
un moment,
à renoncer à ces choses
afin de gagner Christ.
et cela veut dire un moment
que si ces choses,
si je suis dans une période
d'humiliation,
je suis dans une période
de manque d'abondance,
cela ne me détournera pas
du Seigneur
parce que je sais
que Dieu pourvoira.
Ce que Paul est en train de dire,
il est en train de dire
à un moment que
vous pourrez vivre
dans l'humiliation,
dans le manque d'abondance,
vous pourrez avoir la faim,
mais ce qu'il dit à un moment,
ne vous inquiétez de rien,
faites connaître à Dieu
vos besoins
par des prières,
par des supplications,
avec des actions de grâce.
Chacun de nous,
nous serons régulièrement
amenés,
en avançant dans notre vie,
à être confrontés
au fait de savoir
si Dieu est notre tout.
Nous serons confrontés
chaque fois
à savoir un moment
si nous ne sommes pas
en train d'avoir
un cœur partagé.
À un moment,
Dieu peut nous bénir
par rapport à ce que
nous avons pu faire
de notre travail.
Dieu nous bénit
avec un bon travail.
Nous bénissons l'Église
avec les offrandes
que ce travail nous donne.
Mais est-ce que ce travail
n'est pas une idole
dans notre cœur ?
Est-ce que ce travail
n'est pas en train
de me définir
vis-à-vis des autres ?
N'est pas en train
de créer
une sorte de complexe
de supériorité
par rapport à ce que j'ai,
par rapport aux autres ?
Nous avons besoin
de pouvoir veiller
sur nos cœurs.
De pouvoir veiller
Et pourquoi nous devons
veiller sur nos cœurs ?
C'est la suite
de ce verset
qui nous est donné.
Heureux l'homme
qui ne marche pas
selon le conseil
des méchants.
Et donc ça,
c'est le petit B
de ce grand point
sur la suite.
Heureux l'homme
qui ne marche pas
selon le conseil
des méchants,
qui ne s'arrête pas
sur la voie des pécheurs
et qui ne s'assit pas
en compagnie
des moqueurs.
En opposition,
donc il y a un contraste
chaque fois
quand nous lisons le psaume,
il y a un contraste
entre cet homme
qui cherche
à trouver son plaisir
dans la loi de l'éternel
et le méchant
qui ne le trouve pas du tout,
qui ne trouve pas son plaisir
dans la loi de Dieu.
Et donc en opposition
à l'homme
qui trouve son plaisir
dans la loi de l'éternel
et qui la médite
jour et nuit,
c'est bien précisé,
le psaume nous parle
de ceux qui choisissent
la voie contraire.
Il y a certains
qui vont choisir
d'écouter des conseils impies,
il y a certains
qui vont choisir
de pratiquer
ce qui n'honore pas Dieu
et qui dégrade les hommes,
c'est très important
de le préciser.
Il y en a qui vont choisir,
il y a des hommes
qui choisissent
de se moquer de Dieu
dans leurs paroles
et dans leurs actes.
Bien sûr,
quand vous êtes ici en France,
vous pourrez aisément
observer les trois,
quand j'étais en Afrique,
je voyais quand même
que les gens avaient
un peu plus de recul
pour se permettre,
les gens allaient avoir
moins de force
pour insulter Dieu
au nom d'une certaine
liberté d'expression,
se permettre de dire
des choses vis-à-vis de Dieu.
Mais je vois souvent
depuis que je suis revenu
en France,
ici on est beaucoup plus
dans une certaine liberté
au nom de la liberté
d'expression.
Et c'est un peu
cette troisième catégorie
dont la Bible nous parle,
de ceux qui se moquent
de Dieu,
aussi bien dans leurs paroles
et dans leurs actes.
Heureux,
l'homme
qui ne marche pas
selon le conseil des méchants.
Donc la Bible nous parle
de quelqu'un
qui est comme un arbre
planté près d'un cours d'eau,
mais la Bible nous parle
de l'effet inverse.
Si nous ne sommes pas
dans ce cas,
nous sommes comme un arbre
qui est dans le désert,
un arbre qui a,
si vous avez déjà été
dans le désert
et que vous pouvez voir
ces arbres,
il y a certains
qui ont développé
une résistance
dans le désert
à pouvoir se nourrir.
Et donc là,
ça veut dire que leurs racines
vont de plus en plus bas
parce que quand vous allez
de plus en plus bas,
la température est plus fraîche.
Et c'est comme ça
que ces arbres
dans le désert
peuvent vivre.
Mais ces arbres
ne portent pas de fruits.
Généralement,
dans le désert,
vous allez rarement
trouver des arbres
qui portent des fruits,
sauf s'ils sont bien sûr
à côté d'un coin d'eau.
Et la Bible nous dit
ceux qui ne marchent pas
selon les conseils
des méchants.
Aujourd'hui,
on a beaucoup de personnes
et même pour certaines personnes
qui vont dire un moment
qui placent leur confiance
en Dieu,
ce sont des personnes aussi
qui vont choisir
de rechercher
l'approbation des hommes.
Ce sont des personnes
qui vont rechercher
les personnes
qui peuvent leur dire,
qui peuvent les encourager
dans leur voie de péché.
à un moment,
on sait ce que la Bible dit,
mais on va être dérangé
par ce que la Bible dit.
Donc,
on va chercher
le conseil des impies,
on va chercher des gens
qui vont nous encourager
dans nos voies.
Et si ces personnes
nous disent le contraire
de ce qu'on veut entendre,
on va s'éloigner
de ces personnes.
Généralement,
le conseil des impies
va toujours dans le sens
du cœur,
de la perversion
du cœur de l'homme.
Nous devons toujours
être vigilants là-dessus.
J'ai déjà vu
beaucoup de fois,
beaucoup de frères et sœurs
qui se sont détournés
de la voix de Dieu
à cause de ça.
Parce qu'à un moment,
ils ont été confrontés
à la parole.
Ils savaient ce que la parole
de Dieu disait
par rapport à cette relation
qu'ils sont en train
d'entretenir avec un non-croyant.
Mais à un moment,
ils savaient ce que dit la parole,
mais il y a aussi
ce que leur cœur désire.
Et nous devons toujours
faire attention à ce...
Ça, c'est diabolique,
à un moment.
Aujourd'hui,
c'est un proverbe populaire.
Suis les voies de ton cœur.
Pour nous qui sommes sauvés,
nous savons que le cœur est mauvais.
Ne suivons pas les voies
de notre cœur.
Si tu as l'habitude
de te dire ça à un moment,
il faut que je suive
les voies de mon cœur.
Non.
Suis la parole de Dieu.
Les voies du cœur sont perverses.
Elles nous amènent
un moment à vouloir justifier,
à vouloir enrober le péché
pour essayer de calmer
notre conscience
et de le faire accepter
à nous-mêmes et aux autres.
Et c'est comme ça
que des personnes vont trouver
beaucoup d'arguments.
Ils vont chercher,
ils vont même chercher,
ah, mais il y avait ce prophète
dans la Bible
qui avait épousé une prostituée.
Pourquoi je n'irais pas
dans ce sens ?
On va très loin
pour essayer de justifier
en suivant le conseil des impies.
Paul parle de ce genre
de personnes
aussi bien dans ces deux aspects.
Quand on parle
du conseil des méchants,
de celui qui marche,
ceux qui marchent
selon le conseil des méchants,
ceux qui s'arrêtent
sur la voie des pécheurs,
voici ce que Paul nous dit
encore là-dessus.
c'est toujours important
que nous puissions nous rappeler.
La parole est toujours vraie
et elle fait toujours
cet effet aussi
pour nous faire réfléchir là-dessus.
Paul va dire de ces personnes
comme ils ne se sont pas
souciés de connaître Dieu.
C'est-à-dire,
au moment où nous savons
quelle peut être la vérité,
nous savons ce qui est attendu,
mais au moment où nous voulons
suivre les voies de notre cœur,
nous allons essayer
de trouver aussi des excuses.
Comme ils ne se sont pas
souciés de connaître Dieu,
Dieu les a livrés
à leur sens réprouvé
pour commettre des choses indignes.
Étant rempli de toute espèce
d'injustice,
de méchanceté,
de cupidité,
de malice,
on va frauder à la CAF
parce que de toute façon
tout le monde fait ça.
On va frauder à la CAF
parce qu'on va même dire
Dieu voit dans quelle situation
je vis,
Dieu voit que je suis malheureux
et Dieu voit qu'il y en a
qui profitent
et pourquoi moi je ne profiterai pas.
Rempli de cupidité,
de malice,
plein d'envie,
de meurtre,
de querelle,
de ruse,
de malignité,
rapporteur,
médisant,
impie,
arrogant,
hautain,
fanfaron,
ingénieur au mal,
rebelle à leurs parents.
Regardons toutes les pubs
qui se passent à la télé.
Aujourd'hui,
on a démocratisé le fait
qu'un enfant puisse être impoli
envers ses parents,
qu'un enfant puisse répondre
comme il a envie
envers ses parents.
Et on essaie toujours
d'enrober,
on va toujours chercher
à trouver des excuses.
Je regardais hier
une vidéo
où des dames
étaient en train
de justifier
l'adultère
qu'une dame
avait commis.
Et finalement,
elles étaient même
en train de prendre
la défense
de la dame
qui avait commis
l'adultère.
C'est-à-dire,
pendant l'émission,
elles ont réussi
à établir un schéma
pour présenter
que si elle avait
commis l'adultère,
ça peut arriver,
ce sont les autres
qui doivent le comprendre.
Donc,
c'est son mari
qui devait comprendre,
c'est sa fille,
le fruit de l'adultère,
qui devra comprendre,
ce sont tous ceux
qui sont autour d'elle
qui doivent comprendre.
Et bien qu'ils connaissent
le jugement de Dieu,
déclarant dignes de mort
ceux qui commettent
de telles choses,
non seulement ils les font,
mais ils approuvent
ceux qui les font.
Donc,
on va rechercher
le conseil des impies,
on va aller sur la voie
des pécheurs,
parce qu'à un moment,
ça va satisfaire
les envies de notre cœur.
La Bible nous dit
à un moment
que l'homme qui est heureux,
l'homme qui place
sa confiance dans l'éternel,
c'est celui qui ne marche pas
selon les conseils des méchants,
qui ne s'arrête pas
sous la voie des pécheurs.
Et pour nous,
c'est important
de pouvoir considérer
aussi cet aspect
de qui nous recherchons
et comment nous recherchons
un moment
à ce que nos voies
soient approuvées.
Est-ce qu'à un moment,
lorsque je suis confronté
à la parole de Dieu
et qu'elle est vraie
et qu'elle est en train
de tourner mon cœur,
qu'est-ce que je suis
en train de faire ?
Est-ce que je suis en train
de chercher des excuses
ou je suis en train
de chercher aussi
des personnes
qui peuvent me conforter
dans mon excuse ?
Il y a une troisième voie.
C'est Pierre qui en parle aussi,
qui en parle même en détail,
quand on va parler
de ce troisième aspect,
mais qui ne s'assit pas
en compagnie des moqueurs.
Pierre nous dit
dans 2 Pierre 3,
alors pour ceux
qui voulaient relire
dans la référence de Romains,
c'est Romains 1,
verset 28,
28 à 32.
Et là,
dans 2 Pierre 3,
à partir du verset 3,
Pierre dit,
« Sachant avant tout
que dans les derniers jours,
il viendra des moqueurs
avec leur raillerie,
marchant selon
leur propre convoitise
et disant
où est la promesse
de son avènement. »
Les gens pêchent
parce qu'ils ont
cette conviction
que Dieu ne jugera pas.
Les gens vivent
selon les pensées
de leur cœur,
donc tout ce que je viens
de dire,
vivent avec toute espèce
d'injustice,
de méchanceté,
de cupidité,
de malice,
d'envie,
de meurtre,
de querelles,
de ruses,
de malignité
parce qu'ils ont
cette certitude
que Dieu ne les jugera pas.
Et donc,
depuis,
il y en a qui posent
la question,
mais depuis que Dieu
a promis de venir,
où est-ce qu'il est ?
Car depuis que les pères
sont morts,
tout demeure comme
dès le commencement
de la création.
Mais Pierre dit,
ils veulent ignorer
en effet que des cieux
existèrent autrefois
par la parole de Dieu,
de même qu'une terre
tirée de l'eau
est formée au moyen
de l'eau
et que par ces choses
le monde d'alors
périt submergé par l'eau,
tandis que par la même parole
les cieux et la terre
d'à présent
sont gardés
et réservés
pour le feu,
pour le jour
du jugement
et de la ruine
des hommes impies.
Une des choses
qui doit beaucoup
nous réconforter,
ça ne doit pas être
le premier motif.
Le premier motif
pour lequel nous devons
éviter le péché,
c'est de considérer
le mal
que ça fait à Dieu.
Le deuxième motif aussi,
si à un moment
tu ne veux pas considérer
cela,
sache que
Dieu voit tes voies.
À un moment
sur la considération
de beaucoup de choses,
c'est de nous dire
à un moment
que Dieu ne jugera pas,
Dieu ne voit pas nos voies
et donc nous pouvons
nous permettre
de mener
cette vie,
nous pouvons nous permettre
de mener le péché,
de ne pas nous repentir
parce que c'est aussi
très important
de parler de cet aspect
qu'on ne parle pas,
quand on parle de l'homme
qui est heureux
et qui marche
selon le conseil de Dieu,
ce n'est pas quelqu'un
qui est hors du péché,
c'est quelqu'un
qui aura des luttes
comme on peut parler,
c'est quelqu'un
qui va être confronté
au péché,
à la chute.
Mais la grâce de Dieu
lui permet de continuer
à prospérer
près de ce cours d'eau.
Le troisième point
de cette première partie
sur l'homme
qui trouve son plaisir
dans la loi de l'éternel,
c'est justement
sur ce point,
quand il dit un moment,
au verset 2,
donc,
heureux l'homme
mais qui trouve son plaisir
dans la loi de l'éternel
et qui la médite
jour et nuit.
L'homme
qui est heureux
trouve la source
de sa joie
dans la contemplation,
dans l'intériorisation
de la parole de Dieu
et cela lui permet
de marcher
dans l'obéissance.
c'est un point
que j'avais évoqué
dernièrement
lors d'une des dernières
prédications
sur Ézéchiel
et qui nous aide
justement
à tout ce que j'ai cité
dans Romain,
pourquoi nous pouvons vivre
et nous pouvons éviter
ces choses
que j'ai citées
tout à l'heure
dans Romain
et qui caractérisent
l'homme pécheur
et qui nous permettent
de ne pas nous conformer
au monde,
c'est la parole
de Dieu.
Et c'est important
cet aspect,
il dit à un moment
qu'il la médite
jour et nuit.
Là encore,
notre interpellation
c'est de savoir
à quel degré
nous sommes en train
de méditer
la parole de Dieu.
Est-ce qu'il t'est déjà
arrivé de passer
toute une nuit
à étudier
la parole de Dieu ?
C'est le principe
de jour et nuit.
Il faut vraiment
le prendre aussi
de façon littérale
à un moment.
De trouver son plaisir
dans la parole de Dieu
le jour,
de trouver son plaisir
dans la parole de Dieu
la nuit.
Sur cet aspect,
je reviens donc
sur ce sur quoi
j'étais revenu
sur Ezekiel.
Ces aspects
de méditer
la parole de Dieu
jour et nuit,
c'est le fait
d'écouter
la parole de Dieu
avec un cœur honnête
et bon.
chaque fois que nous
sommes confrontés
au fait que Dieu
est en train
de nous parler,
même dans l'exhortation
des frères,
il y a des moments
où nous pouvons
considérer un moment,
il y a des moments
où si des frères
nous exhortent
et que nous savons
que c'est très confrontatif,
nous allons fermer
notre cœur,
nous allons avoir
du mal à accepter.
Mais même dans ces choses,
nous devons prier
en disant,
Seigneur,
accorde-moi de pouvoir
tirer une leçon.
Il se peut même
que je n'ai pas
entièrement tort
dans ce qui est en train
de m'être reproché,
mais je dois prier
pour que Dieu
m'apprenne quelque chose.
Là où je dois
être corrigé,
que Dieu permette
que je sois corrigé.
Il est très important
pour nous
que nous puissions prier
pour que le Seigneur
nous accorde
chaque fois
d'écouter la parole
avec un cœur honnête
et bon.
c'est notre prière
que chaque fois
que nous avons
l'occasion
d'écouter la parole,
que nous soyons
en train
de la laisser
nous confronter,
nous corriger,
même sur certains aspects
qui sont difficiles.
Il y a des aspects,
on va dire un moment,
cette personne
m'a offensé,
ce n'est pas à moi
de demander pardon.
Mais l'aspect
qu'il y a
de la parole de Dieu,
elle va nous dire
un moment que si,
avant de déposer
mon offrande,
je me souviens
que quelqu'un
a quelque chose
contre moi,
je ferai l'effort
de chercher
la réconciliation.
Quand la parole
de Dieu nous parle ainsi,
ça va être très confrontatif,
ça va être très difficile.
Mais ce qu'elle est
en train de nous dire,
c'est d'accepter
la parole
avec un cœur honnête.
C'est ça le principe
d'accepter la parole
avec un cœur honnête.
De laisser
que la parole
nous confronte
et que si nous avons péché,
nous corrigeons.
L'autre jour,
j'avais mon frère
qui,
je crois qu'il avait
eu à prêcher
et il y a un frère
qui est venu lui dire
« J'ai trouvé
le culte
et la prédication
trop longues. »
Mon frère lui a dit
« Est-ce que tu as eu
l'occasion
d'ouvrir ta Bible
cette semaine ? »
Alors,
par la grâce de Dieu,
comme la personne
était croyante,
il ne pouvait pas mentir.
Il lui a dit
« Est-ce que tu as eu
l'occasion
d'ouvrir la Bible
cette semaine ? »
Il a dit
« Non,
je n'ai pas ouvert
la Bible. »
Il lui a dit
« Est-ce que tu étais
à la réunion
de prière ? »
Il lui a dit
« Non,
je n'étais pas
à la réunion
de prière. »
« Est-ce que tu as pu
vivre la communion
avec des frères
et soeurs
dans la semaine ? »
« Non,
je n'ai pas vécu
la communion
avec des frères
et soeurs
dans la semaine. »
Par contre,
il a trouvé
que la prédication
était trop longue.
nous avons besoin
de comprendre
un moment
que
si
Dieu,
par la grâce de Dieu,
je vais venir
là-dessus,
par la grâce de Dieu
à un moment,
nous sommes
comme un arbre
qui est planté
près d'un courant d'eau.
Mais c'est l'arbre
aussi qui doit
produire du fruit.
C'est notre responsabilité
aussi de produire du fruit.
de connaître
la parole de Dieu.
C'est notre responsabilité
déjà d'écouter
la parole de Dieu
avec diligence.
C'est notre responsabilité
de lire la parole
abondamment.
Médite-la jour
et nuit.
C'est notre responsabilité
d'étudier
cette même parole.
Donc,
comme je l'ai dit
au début,
il ne suffit pas
juste de lire
pour lire.
Nous avons besoin
de contempler la parole.
de comprendre
ce qu'elle est en train
de nous dire de Dieu,
de nous dire
de l'œuvre de Dieu.
Et nous avons besoin
de l'intérioriser.
Nous avons besoin
de la mémoriser,
pas seulement
pour les moments difficiles,
parce que malheureusement,
j'ai connu des frères
qui sont bien sauvés,
mais qui ne vont ouvrir
la Bible
que quand ils ont
des difficultés.
C'est quand c'est difficile
que là,
on va...
Même les psaumes,
beaucoup lisent les psaumes
pour chercher du secours
lorsque ça chauffe au travail,
qu'on a un patron
qui est difficile,
un supérieur difficile.
On va lire,
on va faire une prière
contre ce supérieur
et on va chercher
les psaumes
qui nous parlent
de nos ennemis.
Bon, déjà là,
c'est une très mauvaise
interprétation,
mais...
Mais ce que le psalmiste
est en train de nous dire,
quand il dit
médite la jour,
que celui qui est heureux
dans la parole de l'Éternel,
c'est celui qui lit la parole
abondamment,
c'est celui qui étudie
la parole abondamment,
c'est celui qui mémorise
c'est celui qui la médite.
C'est des points très différents,
mais ce sont des points importants.
Si nous ne sommes pas
en train de vivre cette réalité,
de méditer la parole,
de laisser que la parole
soit en train de façonner
notre façon de penser,
notre façon de vivre,
nous serons dans l'autre côté.
La Bible ne nous montre pas,
le psalm 1 est en train
de nous montrer
qu'il n'y a pas une alternative,
il n'y a pas un milieu,
un juste milieu,
il n'y a pas,
il y a les méchants
qui ont choisi
d'ignorer la loi de l'Éternel
et il y a les justes.
Bien sûr,
là,
quand nous parlons des justes,
ce sont ceux qui sont justifiés
par la grâce de Christ.
Mais la Bible ne nous montre pas
quelqu'un qui est au milieu
et qui peut,
non.
Donc,
si nous ne sommes pas
en train de vivre
cette réalité
de nous nourrir
auprès de ce courant d'eau,
nous sommes en train
d'aller vers le conseil impie,
d'aller sur la voie
des pécheurs,
nous sommes en train
de nous asseoir
avec les moqueurs.
et le souci qu'il y a
à un moment,
c'est que quand
nous allons étudier
la parole de Dieu,
nous allons surtout chercher
ce qu'elle peut apporter
pour satisfaire
l'envie de nos cœurs
si nous ne sommes pas
en train de vivre
cette réalité.
Dans Josué,
il est dit
que ce livre de la loi
ne s'éloigne pointe
de ta bouche
dans c'est Josué,
chapitre 1,
verset 8.
Et il reprend donc
ce que le psalmiste dit,
médite le jour et nuit,
c'est Dieu qui parle
à Josué,
que ce livre de la loi
ne s'éloigne pointe
de ta bouche,
médite le jour et nuit
pour agir fidèlement
selon tout ce qui est écrit,
car c'est alors
que tu auras du succès
dans tes entreprises,
c'est alors que tu réussiras.
Quand la parole de Dieu
nous dit ça,
ce n'est pas pour
le succès dans nos vies
parce qu'aujourd'hui encore,
c'est aussi un passage
un peu comme
je puis tout
par celui qui me fortifie,
Josué 1, verset 8
est aussi pris
pour être le passage
qui justifie
toutes les envies
de notre cœur.
Du moment que nous allons
ouvrir la Bible
pour qu'elle trouve
comment elle peut
nous réconforter
dans nos voies
et elle peut nous aider
dans le succès
de nos entreprises,
alors nous sommes heureux.
Non, ce n'est pas
ce que la parole
de Dieu nous dit.
Cette parole est là
pour faire grandir
Christ en nous.
Cette parole est là
afin que dans les temps
d'abondance,
je sois heureux.
Je me réjouisse
dans le Seigneur.
Dans les temps
de disette,
je me réjouisse
dans le Seigneur.
Dans les temps
où j'ai faim,
je me réjouis
dans le Seigneur.
Dans les temps
où je suis dans l'abondance,
je sois en train
de me réjouir
dans le Seigneur.
Mais cette mauvaise
compréhension,
ce sera un moment
que cette parole
ne doit être suffisante
que lorsqu'elle nous apporte
la joie,
elle nous apporte
ce dont nous avons besoin.
Et si elle ne nous donne
pas ce dont nous avons besoin,
alors nous chercherons ailleurs.
Et
excusez-moi,
je...
on va dire
sur le petit dé,
donc toujours
sur le...
sur ce passage
de la réussite
de celui
dont Dieu approuve les voies.
On a
ce passage,
il est comme un arbre
planté près d'un courant d'eau
qui donne son fruit
en sa saison
et dont le feuillage
ne se fléterait pas.
Tout ce qui fait,
lui réussit.
C'est en parallèle
avec ce que nous venons
de lire aussi
dans Josué,
chapitre 1,
verset 8.
Et donc,
comme je vous disais,
dans le psaume,
quand on nous parle
de cet arbre,
on ne parle pas
d'un arbre
qui est comme ça,
qui a...
Non,
on nous parle
la...
comment je disais...
traduction.
Merci.
La traduction littérale,
c'est un arbre
qui a été arraché
de quelque part
et qui a été planté
de façon littérale.
Et c'est un arbre
qui a été planté
près d'un cour d'eau.
Et ce que ça illustre,
ça...
et notre frère Moïse
a prié tout à l'heure
là-dessus,
nous devons être heureux
de la grâce de Dieu
dans notre vie.
Nous devons être heureux
et nous réjouir
dans le Seigneur
parce que déjà
nous devons comprendre
un moment
que nul ne vient à Dieu
si Dieu ne l'attire à lui.
Nous devons comprendre
un moment
que même si nous avons
cette impression aujourd'hui
telle qu'on peut
nous la partager un moment,
ce que la parole de Dieu
nous enseigne un moment,
c'est qu'un cadavre
ne peut pas venir à la vie.
Un cadavre
ne peut pas produire la vie.
Pour que nous ayons la vie,
il a fallu que Dieu
nous donne la vie.
Et lorsque
moi qui ai été sauvé
par la grâce de Dieu,
moi qui ai toutes
ces bénédictions
célestes
en Christ,
je n'arrive pas
à trouver ma joie
ici-bas,
ça traduit quelque chose
de profond.
Si je n'arrive pas
à apprécier le salut
de Christ,
je n'arrive pas
à apprécier
le salut
qui a été fait
par Christ
pour moi
et où je réalise
un moment
que je suis comme cet arbre
qui a été arraché
pour être planté
près d'un cours d'eau,
c'est une grâce
que j'ai reçue.
Et déjà,
vous voyez,
Paul le dit
à un moment
de persévérer
dans les prières
avec des actions
de grâce,
des prières,
des supplications
et des actions
de grâce.
Est-ce qu'il y a
un temps
dans la semaine
où tu t'arrêtes
pour dire merci
au Seigneur ?
Ou tu te laisses
chaque fois submergé
par les problèmes
que tu as ?
D'ailleurs,
à un moment,
tu ne vas peut-être
pas venir le vendredi
parce que tu n'as pas
le cœur à la prière.
Toi,
tu as trop de problèmes.
Peut-être les autres
vont mieux,
ils viendront à la prière.
Mais toi,
tu es dans
la supplication.
Tu ne peux pas être dans...
Tu ne peux pas trouver
la joie
de pouvoir prier.
nous devons nous questionner.
Si à un moment,
nous avons du mal
à pouvoir être
dans les actions
de grâce,
soit ça veut dire
que nous
n'avons pas connu
cette paix
que Dieu nous donne,
soit c'est que nous avons
choisi d'aller
sur la voie des pécheurs.
Nous avons choisi
d'écouter
le conseil de l'impie.
Et le conseil de l'impie,
c'est de faire
ce que les pensées
de ton cœur te disent.
C'était un...
Là,
je prends...
Je n'avais pas
l'exemple
d'Akab.
À un moment,
vous voyez,
Akab,
c'était un roi
d'Israël
et à un moment,
sa femme,
Jézabel,
va le trouver triste
parce qu'à un moment,
Akab avait voulu
acheter une vigne
et le propriétaire
de la vigne
lui a refusé la vigne.
On parle du roi d'Israël
et à cause de ça,
ça l'a mis
dans un état.
Il était tellement triste
que sa femme,
Jézabel,
a remarqué
qu'il était triste.
Elle lui a demandé
« Mais pourquoi toi,
qui es le roi,
tu es aussi triste ? »
Il lui a dit
parce qu'il n'avait pas
eu la vigne
de son voisin.
C'est extraordinaire
de voir
le roi d'Israël
qui aurait pu avoir
d'autres vignes,
un grand champ de vigne,
n'a convoité
que cette vigne.
Et Jézabel
a arrangé les choses,
elle a fait tuer
le propriétaire
de la vigne
et Akab a pu
récupérer la vigne.
Mais ça en dit long
sur les attitudes
de nos cœurs.
À un moment,
on est incapable
de rendre grâce
parce qu'on n'a pas eu
ce qu'on voulait.
On va s'attrister,
on ne va pas pouvoir
trouver notre joie
à lire la parole
parce qu'on n'a pas eu
ce que Dieu
ne nous a pas donné,
ce que nous aurions voulu.
Apprenons à être
dans les actions de grâce.
La Bible nous dit
« Il est comme un arbre
planté près d'un courant d'eau
qui donne son fruit
en sa saison. »
C'est de notre responsabilité
de nous saisir
des bénédictions
qui accompagnent
la grâce de Dieu
et de porter du fruit
qui demeure.
Il va y avoir des saisons,
il peut arriver
selon les saisons,
un arbre qui est planté
près d'un courant d'eau,
il se peut aussi
qu'il ne porte pas de fruit.
Mais sa nature
reste ce qu'il est.
Il reste ce qu'il est.
Ça ne change pas.
Il peut arriver,
et c'est pour ça
que je voulais dire
un moment,
il peut arriver
un moment dans nos vies
que nous traversions
des moments très difficiles
où même ouvrir la Bible
peut être très difficile.
Je ne suis pas
en train de nier ça.
Mais nous devons
comprendre un moment
que parce que nous sommes
plantés près du courant d'eau
qu'est Christ,
nous devons croire
en la grâce de Dieu.
Le rappel de Dieu
lorsque ces difficultés
nous affectent,
c'est de nous rappeler
un moment
que notre salut,
notre persévérance
ne se fait pas
par nos propres efforts.
Et voilà un moment
où nous serons des arbres,
nous serons des arbres
qui n'allons pas porter
des fruits
à certaines périodes,
à certaines saisons
de notre vie,
mais qui allons persévérer
par la grâce de Dieu.
Et Jérémie,
je vous disais,
il prenait même ce passage,
Jérémie 17, verset 7,
qui est pratiquement
le même passage.
Jérémie dit,
béni soit l'homme
qui se confie
dans l'éternel
et dans l'éternel
et l'espérance.
Donc le problème
n'est pas que nous n'ayons
pas de problème.
C'est notre façon
de réagir
vis-à-vis des problèmes.
Quand nous allons
considérer que Dieu
est notre tout,
c'est que quand nous
serons confrontés
aux problèmes,
alors nous viendrons
au pied du roi.
Comme nous avons chanté
au pied de la croix sanglante,
nous venons au pied du roi
présenter nos faiblesses,
présenter nos incapacités
et nous avons toujours
besoin de nous souvenir
que nous sommes faibles
et incapables.
Nous avons un Dieu parfait
qui travaille
dans des hommes imparfaits.
Et souvent,
il nous arrive de l'oublier
lorsque notre feuillage
flétrit,
lorsque nous portons
beaucoup de fruits,
nous sommes en train
de vouloir partager
cette gloire avec Dieu.
Mais il y a des moments
où dans le manque
d'abondance,
dans la disette spirituelle,
Dieu est en train
de nous rappeler
un moment
que c'est sa grâce
qui nous soutient.
Béni soit l'homme,
donc Jérémie 17,
verset 7 à 8,
nous dit,
C'est le miracle de Dieu.
C'est le miracle de Dieu
qui va faire un moment
que même quand nous sommes
au plus fort de notre détresse,
nous avons cette capacité
à avoir un cœur,
une louange
qui vient dans notre cœur.
Il y a eu tellement
de moments,
j'ai entendu les frères
qui vont dire un moment,
même quand j'étais désespéré,
pourquoi Paul,
qui est en prison,
qui est dans des chaînes,
passe son temps
à louer dans la prison
avec Silas ?
C'est parce qu'à un moment,
même au temps
de la sécheresse,
des difficultés,
quand nous nous confions
à l'Éternel,
nous ne cesserons
de porter du fruit.
Nous ne cesserons
d'être des bénédictions
pour ceux
qui le connaissent
et même ceux
qui ne le connaissent pas.
Et donc,
pour nous,
c'est important
de comprendre cela
et surtout
de comprendre
l'importance
de la grâce de Dieu
pour nous
au quotidien,
d'être toujours conscient
de nos faiblesses
et du besoin
que nous avons
que Christ grandisse en nous.
Et voilà pourquoi
je disais à un moment
que nous ne devons jamais
être en train
de chercher
la parole de Dieu
pour qu'elle nous
conforte dans nos voies.
Nous devons être
en train de chercher
la parole de Dieu
afin qu'elle nous amène
à grandir,
à être de plus en plus
conformes à l'image
de Christ.
Le deuxième point,
donc le premier point,
c'était cet aspect de,
le premier point,
c'était la sainteté,
le bonheur selon Dieu
pour un homme
que Dieu approuve.
Et il y a ce deuxième point,
on l'a un peu abordé
en parlant un peu
du contraste
des méchants,
mais le péché
et la misère spirituelle
qui accompagnent
un homme
que Dieu rejette.
Et le,
on va dire un peu
le petit,
le petit tas
de ce deuxième grand point,
c'est ce que nous avions
déjà lu
au verset 4.
Il n'en est pas
ainsi des méchants,
ils sont comme la paille
que le vent dissipe.
La perspective,
c'est que nous devons
toujours comprendre,
nous sommes passés
par là
et voilà pourquoi
nous devons d'autant plus
chérir la grâce
que Dieu nous donne.
Nous devons comprendre
la misère d'une vie
sans Dieu.
Il y a des moments
quand nous sommes en train
d'être des chrétiens
dépressifs,
nous sommes des chrétiens
sans joie,
qui ne sont pas heureux,
c'est parce que nous avons
oublié,
ce qu'est la misère
d'une vie sans Dieu.
Et souvent,
nous attribuons
même les réussites,
certaines choses
que nous faisons bien
aujourd'hui dans la vie,
nous oublions
que nous ne serions pas
en train de les faire
si Christ n'était pas
en train de travailler en nous.
Nous ne serions pas
en train d'aimer
notre épouse
comme nous sommes
en train de l'aimer
si Christ n'était pas
en train de travailler en nous.
Nous ne serions pas
en train d'aimer
nos enfants
comme nous les aimons
si Christ ne travaillait pas
en nous.
Mais nous oublions cela.
il y a des moments
où par le manque
d'action de grâce,
nous prenons ces choses
pour acquises.
En croyant un moment
qu'en étant dans la misère
spirituelle
nous étions avant,
nous serions en train
de bien faire ces choses.
Non.
Nous oublions un moment,
ce qui caractérise
le méchant
dans cette
misère spirituelle
qui accompagne
un homme que Dieu
rejette,
c'est la misère
d'une vie sans Dieu,
d'une vie
qui n'arrive pas
à trouver le bonheur,
il n'arrive pas
à trouver un équilibre,
à trouver quelque chose
qui peut le guider
dans cette vie difficile.
On va chercher
beaucoup de préceptes humains,
on va chercher
beaucoup de choses,
on a des coachs,
on a des coachs de vie,
aujourd'hui,
il y a des coachs de vie
pour tout.
Les gens ont des coachs
de vie pour tout,
pour qu'ils puissent
donner un sens.
Alors que dans certains cas,
si tu as besoin
de maigrir,
ça veut dire
qu'il suffit un peu
de moins manger,
d'être moins goûtant,
mais il faut un coach de vie
pour pouvoir t'expliquer ça.
Les hommes vivent
des situations,
ils ne peuvent pas
connaître la paix
et souvent,
le souci que nous avons,
c'est que souvent,
comme nous sommes souvent
entre croyants
et qu'on partage
les choses,
on n'arrive pas toujours
à réaliser
ce qu'un homme
éloigné de Dieu
peut vivre,
ce que certaines personnes
traversent sans Dieu
et nous n'arrivons pas
apprécier la grâce
de Dieu pour nous.
Mais la Bible dit
qu'il n'en est pas
ainsi des méchants.
S'il y a l'homme
qui est heureux
et qui médite
la parole de Dieu
jour et nuit,
il y a le méchant
qui est comme la paille
que le vent dissipe,
c'est-à-dire quelque chose
sans valeur
et qui est balayé
par le vent.
Et le passage,
la Bible nous parle même,
il y a un passage
qui nous dit à un moment
que l'homme qui est
sans Dieu,
l'homme qui est
dans cette misère spirituelle,
c'est quelqu'un qui vit,
c'est comme un arbre
qui est dans une terre salée,
quelqu'un qui est comme
dans une terre salée
sans habitants.
Une terre salée
et sans habitants.
Et aujourd'hui,
nous voyons
beaucoup de personnes
qui vont dire
à un moment
je suis malheureux,
des gens qui sont
dans la solitude
et pourtant,
ils vivent dans des quartiers.
On peut comprendre
que tu sois dans la solitude
si tu vis dans un village
éloigné
et que le premier habitant
est à une heure
de chez toi.
Là, tu vis dans la solitude.
Mais nous ne vivons pas
dans la solitude
et pourtant,
c'est une société
qui est dans la solitude
parce que c'est une société
qui est sans Dieu.
Et donc,
les personnes
ont l'impression
de vivre même
dans une terre
qui est sans habitants
alors que
dans le métro
et autres,
ils croisent
ces personnes
chaque jour.
Mais nous devons chérir,
nous devons trouver
notre joie,
nous devons être heureux.
Le méchant n'a pas
cette joie.
Le méchant
est dans une terre
désolée,
il est sans paix,
il est sans bonheur.
parce qu'il n'a pas Dieu.
Le deuxième petit point
sur cette partie
de
par rapport
à celui
dont Dieu
n'approuve pas
les voies,
c'est
pourquoi
les méchants
ne résistent pas
au jour du jugement
ni les pécheurs
dans l'assemblée
des justes.
même si aujourd'hui
je viens de parler
de ces personnes
qui n'ont pas de paix,
je viens de parler
de ces personnes
qui
n'ont pas de...
Vous voyez,
pendant le Covid,
ça nous a donné
une idée un peu
de ce que c'est la paix
selon Dieu
et ce que c'est la paix
selon le monde.
Nous avons vu
comment les rouleaux
de PQ ont disparu,
comment les gens
ont paniqué
pour beaucoup de choses,
mais qui reflètent
à un moment
l'état du cœur.
Et donc aujourd'hui,
même si ces personnes
veulent se convaincre
de vivre
comme si rien
ne pouvait les atteindre,
même après leur mort,
puisque ça,
on va le voir
beaucoup dans les réseaux,
les gens qui vont dire
je ne crois pas
qu'il y ait quelque chose
après la mort,
mais la conclusion
du psaume 1,
cette conclusion
est sans appel.
Il y a quelque chose
après la mort.
Pour ceux
dont Dieu rejette
les voies
et connaîtront
le châtiment divin,
Dieu ne prend pas plaisir
au mal
et celui qui commet
l'iniquité
n'a pas de place
auprès de Dieu.
On peut se séduire
en appelant
le bien mal
et le mal bien,
mais la parole
de Dieu
est juste et vraie.
Le méchant
va dans sa considération,
ce que le psaume
nous dit à un moment,
c'est que le méchant
ne considère pas
la loi de l'éternel
aussi bien
dans la parole révélée
que dans ce qui peut être
visible de ses yeux,
mais la parole
de Dieu est juste,
elle est vraie
et Dieu sera toujours
élevé par le jugement,
que ce soit un jugement
temporaire,
définitif
et Dieu sera toujours
sanctifié par sa justice.
Et sur la conclusion,
ça peut être un peu
le grand trois de ça,
car l'éternel connaît
la voie des justes
et la voie des pécheurs
mène à la ruine.
C'est...
Donc,
sur le psaume,
le psaume nous présente
au début,
heureux l'homme
qui marche
selon,
dans la voie
de l'éternel,
qui médite
la voie de l'éternel
et qui est comme un arbre
planté près d'un courant d'eau.
Ensuite,
la parole nous parle
qu'il n'en est pas
ainsi des méchants,
qui sont éloignés,
qui ne peuvent pas...
Bien sûr,
il y a la grâce commune,
nous avons tous le soleil,
nous avons toutes ces choses,
mais la paix
que Dieu nous donne...
Et voilà pourquoi
le Seigneur Jésus-Christ
nous disait un moment
que la paix qu'il donne,
c'est une paix
que le monde
ne peut pas connaître.
Il y a de ces aspects
où le monde,
même dans la grâce commune,
même dans les bénédictions
que Dieu accorde au monde,
il y a des choses
où l'homme
qui est éloigné de Dieu
ne peut pas connaître la paix.
L'homme qui est éloigné
de Dieu
ne peut pas connaître la joie.
Et la Bible nous dit
que Dieu connaît
toutes les voies des hommes.
Pour nous,
une conclusion
que nous pouvons avoir
lorsque
on nous dit
car l'Éternel
connaît la voie des justes,
pour nous,
une des conclusions
que nous pouvons avoir
avec ce psaume 1
et même par rapport
à ce que je vous ai
prêché ce matin,
c'est de comprendre
l'importance pour nous
de ce que Paul disait
dans Philippiens
à un moment,
que Christ doit être
notre tout.
Bien sûr,
il peut nous arriver
quand nous parlons
de cet aspect,
je crois que je l'avais partagé
pendant la retraite,
quand la Bible nous parle
que Christ soit notre tout
et que toute chose
soit une perte,
nous devons un peu
le voir comme,
pas comme les moines
qui se retiraient
dans un monastère
et qui a abandonné
toutes choses.
Non,
c'est que nous savons
à un moment
que nous aurons des voitures,
nous pourrons avoir
des maisons,
toutes ces choses,
mais ces choses
seront toujours
des gains pour Christ.
Ce sont toujours
des choses
pour que nous puissions
être en bénédiction,
mais ce ne sont pas
des choses
qui vont créer
un attachement
ou qui vont définir
notre culte à Dieu.
Si j'ai une voiture,
je rends grâce à Dieu.
Si je n'ai pas de voiture,
En ce moment,
je n'ai pas de voiture,
je rends grâce à Dieu.
Ce n'est pas facile
là où je suis.
Mais le Seigneur
nous exhorte
et prenons conscience
de ça,
c'est pour ça
que j'avais dit au début,
si aujourd'hui,
pour toi,
c'est très difficile,
c'est très inconcevable
de prier en disant
je suis dans la joie
quand je suis dans l'abondance,
quand je suis dans la disette,
tu as besoin de prier
pour que Dieu
te donne un cœur
qui apprenne
à être content
de l'état
dans lequel tu te trouves.
Le Seigneur Jésus-Christ
nous dit
dans Matthieu 7
au verset 13 à 14,
entrez par la porte étroite.
La porte étroite,
ça veut dire que
si vous avez déjà
essayé de rentrer
ou de passer
par une porte étroite,
vous ne pouvez pas prendre
si vous êtes chargé
ou autre,
non.
Ce principe,
c'est un moment
que tu passes
juste avec ce que tu es.
Entrez par la porte étroite,
car large est la porte,
spacieux est le chemin
qui mène à la perdition.
Il y en a beaucoup
qui rentrent par là.
Le chemin du moindre sacrifice,
le chemin,
même un moment
où tu ne médites pas
la parole de Dieu
parce que tu trouves
un moment
que sacrifier
six heures de sommeil,
c'est trop.
Donc,
tu te dis un moment,
non,
moi,
je ne pourrais jamais
étudier la parole de Dieu
la nuit,
c'est fait pour dormir.
Mais médite
la jour et nuit.
s'il faut que tu mettes
des temps à part
pour pouvoir étudier
la parole,
passe par cette porte étroite,
moins de sommeil,
plus de connaissances
de Christ.
Et il précise,
mais étroite est la porte,
resserrer le chemin
qui mène à la vie
et il y en a peu
qui les trouvent.
Je me souviens,
je ne sais pas
si certains connaissent,
il y a un tableau
qui a été fait
à partir de ce passage
de Matthieu 7,
verset 13 à 14.
Si certains connaissent,
c'est un chemin,
c'est un tableau
qui présente les deux chemins.
Donc,
il y a la porte qui est large
et qui montre un peu
tous les péchés,
qui jalonnent
le chemin qui est large
et qui montre à un moment
le chemin qui est étroit
et tout ce qui jalonne
le chemin est étroit.
Il y a même un lion
qui va attaquer
à un moment,
quelque part.
Et il y a la cité céleste
qui est au bout.
Lorsque nous abondons
dans les actions de grâce,
nous n'oublions pas
quelle est la finalité
de notre vie.
La finalité de notre vie
n'est pas ici-bas.
La définition de ta vie
n'est pas liée
au travail que tu as.
La définition de ta vie
est liée
à ton identité en Christ.
Et à partir de cela,
pour toi,
la plus grande joie
et même le bonheur
que tu vas trouver,
même quand les choses
que tu aimerais avoir,
tu ne les as pas,
c'est l'espérance
de la gloire
de pouvoir être avec Christ.
et je voudrais finir,
pour nous exhorter,
je vais finir avec ce passage.
Je pense que
Pierre était un peu
dans le même esprit
que de la même façon
dont je vous exhorte.
Je finis avec cette lecture
et ce sera suffisant aussi
comme conclusion aussi là-dessus.
dans 2 Pierre 3,
à partir du verset 8,
Pierre nous dit
« Mais il est une chose bien-aimée
que vous ne devez pas ignorer,
c'est que devant le Seigneur,
un jour est comme mille ans
et mille ans sont comme un jour.
Le Seigneur ne tarde pas
dans l'accomplissement de la promesse
comme quelques-uns le croient.
Mais il use de patience envers vous,
ne voulant pas qu'aucun périsse,
mais voulant que tous arrivent
à la repentance. »
Le jour du Seigneur
viendra comme un voleur.
« En ce jour,
les cieux passeront avec fracas,
les éléments embrasés
se dissoudront
et la terre,
avec les œuvres
qu'elle renferme,
sera consumée. »
Et la conclusion de Pierre
« Puisque donc toutes ces choses
doivent se dissoudre,
qu'elles ne doivent pas être
la sainteté de votre conduite
et votre piété.
Tandis que vous attendez
et hâtez l'avènement
du jour de Dieu
à cause duquel
les cieux enflammés
se dissoudront
et les éléments embrasés
se fonderont,
mais nous attendons
selon sa promesse,
de nouveaux cieux
et une nouvelle terre
où la justice habitera. »
C'est pourquoi,
bien-aimés,
en attendant ces choses,
c'est l'exhortation
du psaume 1,
« C'est pourquoi,
bien-aimés,
en attendant ces choses,
appliquez-vous
à être trouvés par lui
sans tâche
et irrépréhensibles
dans la paix.
croyez que la patience
de notre Seigneur
est votre salut
comme notre bien-aimé
frère Paul
vous l'a aussi écrit
selon la sagesse
qui lui a été donnée.
C'est ce qu'il fait
dans toutes les lettres
où il parle de ces choses
dans lesquelles
il y a des points
difficiles à comprendre,
dont les personnes
ignorantes et mal affermies
tordent le sens
comme celui
des autres écritures
pour leurs propres ruines.
Vous donc,
bien-aimés
qui êtes avertis,
mettez-vous
sur vos gardes
de peur contraînée
par l'égarement
des impies,
vous ne veniez
à déchoir
de votre fermeté,
mais croissez
dans la grâce
et dans la connaissance
de notre Seigneur
et Sauveur Jésus-Christ.
À lui soit la gloire,
maintenant
et pour l'éternité.
Amen.
Prions.